[Music]
actually worried about this fiscal cliff
you're worried about it do you know what
it is no it's getting close
yeah yeah when it comes to solving the
fiscal cliff is the latest Washington
insiders described John Boehner as firm
but hopeful that's what they wrote yeah
in response [ __ ] wife said then
they've got less than three minutes to
settle this thing that's true that's a
to that him
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah oh that's gonna get old fast
according to a new poll that just came
out most Americans think that Santa
Claus is a Democrat yeah which is really
odd because when you think fat old white
man who hires unskilled labor
I think Republican
[Music]
Lulla that's him yelling at the Iron Man
yeah yeah scolding the L yes thanks pal
sure you've got my back got it
happy holidays Happy Holidays to
everybody just this is interesting think
about it just five days left of Hanukkah
for my Jewish friends just 14 days left
till Christmas from my Christian friends
and just 10 days left to live for my
Mayan friends
[Applause]
[Music]
you just cut to a mine in the crowd
it's all of us though it can be all of
us ah
alright whatever wait a minute that
doomsday thinks just for them right
oh no it's for everybody oh for the for
the first time ever Sesame Street is
going to be tackling the issue of
divorce and that cool yeah they want to
make it clear that it's never the
child's fault and Ernie and Bert will
remain friends today the the CEO of
Yahoo announced a faster simpler version
of Yahoo Mail now it's called Gmail
[Applause]
the future this the government this is a
device I used to add I've heard of the
government
one of these days if only I had the
power to do something about you know the
government suspects that the makers of
some apps are stealing private
information from children yeah the most
suspicious children's app is one called
Dora the PIN number Explorer just
backpack and map with her my kids have
their I have a kid all of her fan of the
young people the crowd like what's he
talking to has a backpack whose name is
backpack
they were up all night thinking of that
one right what do we call map
let's call Matt Matt yeah look at me
picking on the writers at Dora the
Explorer somebody's cranky
check this out gang this year that's
mine on transition transition hey gang
get the skinny on this yabo this year
over 1500 soldiers were kicked out of
the Armed Forces for being overweight
yeah yeah and half of our fighter pilots
are now being charged for two seats true
story let's just keep moving
hey according to a global study global
study just came out American kids are
way behind Asian kids in math and
science yeah but don't worry American
kids are still way ahead in buying stuff
made by Asian kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wait a minute this dance does not go
with the USA champ No